president Trump's sudden ban on
transgender servicemembers triggered
protests on both coasts in New York
people carrying resist signs gathered in
Times Square San Francisco City Hall was
bathed in colourful lights in support of
transgender people in the military on
Twitter the president promised to
reverse President Obama's 2016 decision
to allow transgender troops to serve
openly he tweeted the US quote will not
accept or allow transgender individuals
to serve in any capacity in the US
military
now the announcement was quickly met
with bipartisan criticism Arizona
Republican and former prisoner of war
John McCain wrote any American who meets
current medical and readiness standards
should be allowed to continue serving
Jen Crawford is at the Pentagon where
the military is trying to figure out
what to do next
Jan good morning good morning Nora the
heads of all four military branches had
requested a delay in the Obama era
policy pending a review that was due
later this year so the decision
announced on Twitter caught Washington
by surprise president Trump's
announcement received a cool reaction
from members of his own party our troops
do not discriminate while Democrats
rallied outside the Capitol arguing the
change could make the country less safe
President Trump has chosen this day to
commit an act of cowardice the White
House said the move was necessary to
preserve combat readiness the decision
is based on a military decision it's not
meant to be anything more than that
during his January confirmation hearing
Secretary of Defense James Madison 'old
a sweeping policy reversal for all LGBT
service members was unnecessary frankly
senator I've never cared much about two
consenting adults and who they go to bed
with estimates of the number of
transgender individuals serving in the
military vary from 1,300 to more than
15,000 and while the president warned
their continued service would add
tremendous medical costs a 2016 study
found related treatments would add at
most 1/10 of 1% or less than 9 million
dollars to military health care spending
during the campaign President Trump
courted gay and transgender voters l G B
T is starting to like Donald Trump very
much like this really is like a slap to
the face
transgender veteran Leila Ireland served
12 years in the Army there's not a lot
of people that know that I'm transgender
and her husband Logan is currently an
Army Staff Sergeant who served two tours
in Afghanistan we don't know what's
going to happen that puts us in a
precarious situation you know we have
aspirations as people as human beings
now for the president's new proposal
right now it's no more than a series of
tweets I'd neither the White House nor
the Pentagon has said exactly what will
happen to the thousands of transgender
uniformed service members who are
currently in uniform charlie Jan
Crawford at the Pentagon Jen thanks